and it was Mahatma Gandhi who said the
planet can produce enough for human need
but not human greed so you're the
American dairy industry in the 90s for
the past 100 years or so you have been
thriving reaping the benefits of the
entire U.S population being basically
dependent on cow's milk milk was viewed
as something everyone needed like
toothpaste or a car practically every
single American Family across the
country was buying milk on a daily basis
in the 50s milk Untouched by human hair
today milk comes to the customer whether
at home store or restaurant at the peak
of its triple goodness fresh pure and
energizing enriched by added vitamins
which meant a lot of dollar signs for
the industry but now you are facing a
big problem people weren't buying milk
anymore they're too enticed by a cold
fresh competitor on the beverage scene
soft drinks soda has been around for a
while but in the 90s big Brands like
Coca-Cola and Snapple took their
marketing to the next level
[Music]
[Music]
and by the 90s soft drinks have
successfully built a reputation of being
the drink for young hip people unlike
milk which gained the reputation of
being a nuisance that parents made you
drink something had to be done so you
established the California milk
processor board a very vague unassuming
name for a propaganda machine behind its
big name the California milk processor
board was started as a non-profit
marketing organization with the goal of
getting people to buy and drink more
milk no matter what it took for years
you have been trying to sell milk by
telling everyone that it was healthy for
them and their children that milk was an
essential ingredient to the kids growing
up big and strong
drink your milk kids I don't want milk
milk's for babies yeah babies well yeah
well I happen to know that milk helps
build strong bones so drink up well Mr
Miller told me he never drinks milk look
at him yeah
hi kids
[Music]
oh that's not good
nobody cared about that anymore soda is
packed with sugar and yet it was still
flying off the shelves you needed to
come up with a new angle to compete so
the board's advertising agency sets up a
load of research experiments they put
hidden cameras in their own offices to
see their stats reaction when they went
to the fridge and realize there was no
milk left the reaction was always the
same total disappointments that's when
they found the emotion they could tap
into the emotional trigger they could
latch onto the frustration of running
out of milk I mean seriously think about
how annoying it is when you go to grab a
bowl of cereal only to open the fridge
and discover there's not a single drop
of milk left it is the worst this little
moment of frustration sparked big nose
Infamous advertising campaign
[Applause]
[Music]
and that was the Vienna wood dancing d
one of my all-time favorites and now
let's make that random call with today's
Ten Thousand Dollar Question and it's a
tough one who shot Alexander Hamilton in
that famous duel
all right let's go to the phones and see
who's out there
[Music]
hello for ten thousand dollars
[Music]
[Music]
I'm sorry maybe next time
is this
milk this commercial was directed by
none other than Michael Bay the director
of Transformers of course
people went crazy for this hilarious
commercial as soon as it aired and so
began one of the most iconic advertising
campaigns in history soon the whole
country would know the trademark slogan
hey I'm you from the future
you're me
I know drink this
[ __ ] get drunken
[Music]
[Music]
come on again
[Music]
I'm holding
[Music]
on it what you don't like interrupted
dreams
that might just be a drink for that
every celebrity would soon be saying got
milk with a white mustache across their
upper lip but got milk was not the first
time the dairy industry had tried to
trick the public into drinking more milk
in fact the milk industry had actually
been colluding with the government for
decades a pack a cartel between big milk
and big governments to push the drink as
a crucial part of a balanced diets that
parents were irresponsible if they
weren't making their kids drink a few
cups of milk a day but is any of it true
or have we been brainwashed into
drinking something that's actually
killing us that we were never meant to
consume while big milk and big
government lined their own Pockets my
name is Jake Tran I make documentaries
on money power war and crime in my team
subscribe for more if you want to win a
thousand dollars cash starting right now
we're picking a random Instagram
follower every single week to win you
just have to be following me at Jake
Tren just got this new handle and you're
automatically entered watch out for fake
accounts I will never message you asking
for money and this is the truth behind
the milk cartel
[Music]
everything
an important food for the health of the
nation
[Music]
pasteurized milk a safe food trusted by
millions of people and important in
every diet of special importance to
children and invalids for all these
people asterisation is a guarantee of
safety there is no such thing as partly
safe milk
pasteurization is a scientific job a
responsible job
[Applause]
the biggest Dairy company today is
Nestle Nestle has nearly 40 billion
dollars in debts that is an insane
amount of debts giant corporations like
Nestle can handle this kind of debts but
regular people like you and I no way
drowning in credit card debt and high
interest debt keeps you down it prevents
you from moving forward in life but what
if there was a different way else what
if you could get a new loan at a smarter
interest rates use that new loan to pay
off your high interest debts so you're
left with only one fixed monthly payment
and clear payoff dates so you can escape
this vicious cycle of debt once and for
all think about the weight that would be
lifted off your shoulders if you had
this way of taking care of your debts
well that's where upstart comes in
upstart is a quick and simple way to get
a personal loan that only requires one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff dates that you can use to pay off
your high interest debts and it's all
done online with easy to understand
payment terms that way you'll know
exactly how much you're paying and for
how long over 1.8 million people have
taken advantage of upstart to pay off
their credit cards consolidate High
interest debts or to find a personal
expense and the great thing about
upstart is that it considers factors
other than just your credit score
upstart looks at your income employment
and other information to get you a
smarter rate for your loan your loan
offer could be anywhere from one
thousand to fifty thousand dollars and
you can check your rate in minutes
without impacting your credit score if
you end up getting a loan you could have
access to your funds in as little as one
business day and you can check your rate
without impacting your credit score
right now at upstart.com Jake that's
upstart.com Jake to check your rate
today don't forget to use our link to
let them know we sent you loan amounts
would be determined based on your credit
income and other certain information
provided in your loan application that's
upstar.com Jake thanks to upstart for
sponsoring this video
foreign
[Applause]
BCE in Western Europe and lots of
exciting things are happening
foreign
civilizations are being built up The
Potter's Wheel was just invented and
everyone is about to start writing
throughout all these developments people
are beginning to domesticate animals as
well horses chickens sheep cows the
farmers that were taking care of these
animals started thinking Hmm what if we
drink our cow's milk and that's how the
whole trend of drinking milk in Europe
and North America began
before this point the only milk humans
ever consumed was their mothers humans
would actually lose the enzyme in their
body needed to digest milk or lactase
after infancy so adults who drink it
used to get really sick but drinking
milk served these people with a crucial
evolutionary Advantage it was hard being
a human around this time getting all the
nutrients you needed wasn't as simple as
a trip to the grocery store having a
ready-made drink on hand with so many
useful nutrients was a really good thing
a lot of the people who lived in areas
that drank cow's milk ended up having an
your time surviving so it wasn't long
before their genes evolved to keep
digesting lactase into adulthood
[Music]
and now they could drink milk without
getting sick that's a trait that many of
the people in Europe in North America
still have today it's why the milk
industry boomed in these areas unlike
places that didn't drink milk around
this time like East Asia where basically
everyone in the whole region is lactose
intolerant including Jake so even though
some humans have been drinking milk for
thousands of years in the grand scheme
of things it's still way less than 0.1
percent of our time on Earth but it
wasn't until the 20th century that Dairy
became its own industry
foreign
[Applause]
started being a big thing during World
War One the U.S actually sent off over
750 million pounds of condensed milk to
help its allies overseas and Americans
were using it to substitute calories
during food rationing but after the war
people didn't need milk as much anymore
and Farms were left with a ridiculous
amount of dairy that no one wanted
can't let our important Farmers go out
of business now can we so much like the
sugar industry the U.S government
stepped in to save the day the U.S
government started telling the public
that milk was the key to being healthy
that it's good for your bones vitamin D
milk helps build strong bones and teeth
by 1926 experts were recommending that
children drink a pint of milk every day
can you imagine if you could sell a
product that the US government was
pushing people so hard to consume every
single day think about how easier that
would make your life every time an
obstacle got in the way of the milk
industry the government would step in to
remove it in 1937 the government even
set a minimum price that farmers had to
be paid for their milk price fixing like
the same thing that Us's Arch Enemy was
doing at the time the Soviet Union and
it's basically the same system we use
today once the second world war happened
demand for milk went through the roof
again and again nobody was buying milk
after the war ended so there was way too
much leftover product like me millions
of pounds can you guess what happens
next we can't let our Dairy Farmers
suffer farmers are the backbone of our
economy so the government buys up all
their extra Supply with taxpayer dollars
they put out a new policy that bled 2
billion dollars into the dairy industry
over four years by buying the surplus of
dairy products basically Americans
stopped buying milk so the government
forced them to buy milk at the point of
a gun through your tax dollars and when
you hear Dairy Farmers you imagine cute
mom and pop Farmers trying to make ends
meet with a few cows here and there but
that's not the case at all no we're
talking about your money being used to
fund this this and this
now the U.S government has a stockpile
of milk and other dairy supplies with no
idea what to do with them they send some
overseas and give a bunch to school
lunch programs but mainly all of these
dairy products sat in storage by 1983
the US government had around three
billion pounds of excess Dairy stored
away one USDA official actually said
probably the cheapest and most practical
thing to do would be to dump it in the
ocean to make up for it the federal
government was now recommending that
children drink four glasses of milk a
day soon the dairy checkoff program was
created allowing Dairy Farmers to be
used for things like promotional
campaigns with fast food brands
encouraging the big fast food chains to
use even more Dairy then in the 1990s
came the famous got milk ad campaign
no
one of the most well-known ads of Our
Generation it might even be called a
cultural icon at one point eighty
percent of all U.S consumers heard or
saw the phrase got milk at least once
per day good milk got milk put out over
70 ads during the campaign's Epic
20-year run and it was finally retired
in 2014 and replaced with the
catchphrase milk life which is
admittedly a lot less catchy but this
iconic advertisement campaign must have
sold a bunch of milk right well not
really milk sales went up a little in
California but just enough to save the
industry from Total collapse and overall
Americans are still drinking way less
milk than they used to the dairy
industry just couldn't seem to hold on
to its Glory Days of the 50s there was
just too much competition and too many
people becoming turned off by milk of
course this never stopped the government
from coming to save the milk industry
one last time as recently as 2018 the
government gave out a one billion dollar
handout to the dwindling dairy industry
the funds are supposed to go towards
helping the industry recover from
plummeting dairy prices as with
everything else the government does they
never learned our lesson
[Music]
[Applause]
why is it good well it's good for the
bombs
foreign teeth everything great food the
milk makes strong bones
TV that's where we get all our good
information right
degraded into American culture as a
symbol of Health calcium strong bones
milk it does a body good but recently
people have started becoming suspicious
of it with the government pushing people
to drink milk so much it makes you stop
and wonder is it even healthy for you
and the answer is sometimes the whole
purpose of milk is that it's a superfood
for babies whose digestive system is
still developing it provides them with
all nutrients vitamins and calories they
need to survive lactose is a sugar
milk sugar
it's glucose
attached to galactose it's what we call
a disaccharide and when you're a little
baby who's nursing you have an enzyme
that breaks those apart and you can
absorb them but after the age of weaning
normally you lose that enzyme we don't
have the enzyme to digest milk past the
age of two these properties still exist
in other animals milk it's an
inexpensive and easy source of protein
calcium vitamin A and more
so milk can be an incredibly important
part of people's diet in places that
struggle to get enough food but the
thing is the good stuff in milk isn't
only found in milk there's protein in
tofu and beans there's calcium and chia
seeds and almonds carrots pumpkin and
kale are all rich in vitamin A while
drinking milk has risks that many of
these Foods don't have like intestinal
bleeding in infants cow's milk earlier
six months eight months 10 months even
12 months you're taking a chance the
child is going to lose iron from from
occult gastrointestinal bleeding and
because milk doesn't contain iron as
much and it's not as absorbable as this
from breast milk now they're going to be
the potential is going to be there for
iron deficiency when they're young and
iron deficiency in a young child can
have effects on reducing their
intelligence and that reduction
intelligence can be there permanently
for the rest of their life high levels
of cholesterol and saturated fat that
can increase your risk of heart disease
if you look at what's in milk and other
dairy products it's a recipe for a heart
attack it's got an awful lot of fat in
it mostly saturated fat that kind of
that raises cholesterol so if there was
one food to wipe out to prevent heart
disease that would be cheese and butter
but when you have heart disease you'd be
crazy to eat diet to eat pouring cheese
and butter on your foods but you know go
to a hospital see what they feed them
see what they feed people coming out of
bypass surgery see what they bring to
you when you're in when you're in
hospital they bring you all kinds of
high saturated fat dairy products and
maybe
cancer a 2001 Harvard study showed that
having the recommended serving size of
dairy could increase rates of prostate
cancer in men plus even the benefits
that milk is supposed to have might not
be accurate definitely a very strong
language prostate cancer possibly even
stronger than there is with smoking and
lung cancer
insulin-like growth factor which is a
hormone that mama cow puts in the milk
for baby cow to grow and human mothers
do the same thing for in in human breast
milk because milk is designed to make
things grow and so the mother cow is
putting growth factors in hormones and
nutrients into the milk to cause changes
in the calf's body that make the calves
cells grow when you're an adult you
don't need any more growth hormone
growth hormone basically is looking
around for something to do if it finds a
non-self cell or a mutated cell then it
can act on those cancerous cells and
increase gross of growth of cancer cells
one study found that even moderate
amounts of dairy milk consumption can
increase women's risk of breast cancer
up to 80 percent and yet this isn't even
mentioned on our National Breast Cancer
Foundation website though we're still
promoting dairy products saying they're
important for bone health
for years the industry has maintained
that drinking milk makes your bones
stronger but a 2012 study found that
active children who drink a lot of milk
actually got more bone fractures than
those who didn't previous studies had
discovered the same thing and they found
that the countries where they were
consuming the most milk the countries
are there consuming the most calcium had
the highest fracture rates it's actually
opposite of what you would think at
Harvard the nurse's health study tracked
women
more than 70 thousand women for over 18
years what they found is those who drank
the most milk had absolutely no
protection against hip fractures at all
the idea that calcium is going to build
strong bones is a myth over and over and
over again they do these studies they
put more calcium in the system
and it doesn't help the bones when you
consume animal protein such is found in
dairy products or meats or or eggs you
pull calcium from your bones and excrete
it in your urine it's the protein in our
dairy-based foods that makes it more
difficult for us to keep the calcium
that we're getting from dairy products
in our bodies what happens is when
you're consuming the animal protein your
blood becomes acidic and your body
reacts by pulling calcium from the bones
as as a kind of buffer to to neutralize
the blood on top of being not great for
our bodies the milk industry is horrible
for the planet and animals seventy
percent of formerly forested Amazon is
now being used for pasture land and more
is being used to raise crops to feed the
animals so this is one of the biggest
sources of deforestation in the world
20 meat and dairy companies are
responsible for more greenhouse gas
emissions than the countries of Germany
Britain or France it's methane
the cattle industry is contributing
you know a gas that has 23 times the
power to create a greenhouse effect that
does the CO2 from Cars
agriculture has grown enormously people
consume five times as much animal
products today as they did 50 years ago
our consumption will double again in the
next 50 years already the atmosphere
we're breathing has more than twice as
much methane as it did a century ago the
one animal that's the most powerful
emitter of methane are dairy cows they
need to eat an enormous amount of food
to produce all that milk according to
the UN it's a bigger Source than all the
cars and trucks and planes and trains
put together these Dairy corporations
turn their profit by forcing cows to get
pregnant and taking away their babies to
milk them over and over again until
they're slaughtered when their bodies
can't produce anymore it's a painful and
miserable existence so sure milk might
not be exactly poisonous but it's doing
more harm than good in today's society
and that's leading to the industry's
downfall milk was a bad choice
foreign
[Applause]
the milk and dairy industry is dying or
at least in the way it used to exist is
dying
the only companies profiting from milk
anymore are the conglomerates the ones
who treat cows the worst and do the most
damage to the environment
on the other hand
small family-run farms that have been in
business for Generations are closing
down
more than half of the dairy farms that
were around in 1992 are now gone
the fact is people don't want milk
anymore they're eating less cereal
people want soda and energy drinks not
milk
and every year dairy-free milk
alternatives are becoming more popular
by 2028 the dairy alternative Market
will be worth more than 50 billion
dollars while the animal milk Market
struggles to keep up
milk might have been a billion dollar
racket for the last hundred years but
looks like the cartel
it's finally collapsing
I don't know about you guys but I
personally love these videos about
cartels I find them super fascinating so
let me know what you thought in the
comments below and if you are new here
my name is Jake and this is one of the
biggest channels for documentaries on
money power and crime we make multiple
documentaries every single week for free
so if you enjoyed this one click that
subscribe button and if you want longer
documentaries that are too controversial
to post publicly click that join button
below we just put out a new one called
the bin Laden papers which is super good
and it would definitely get demonetized
right away because it talks about Bin
Laden and 911 all the things YouTube
doesn't like and you can watch it right
away by clicking that join button below
there's a refund policy too so if you
join and you don't think it's worth it
just email me and I will personally
refund you the money that is going to
wrap it up stay dangerous out there and
I will see you guys in the next one
foreign